lucy congratulations on borrego and and
you get to be the boss too
well
yeah
kind of yeah
kind of
as as an exec as an executive producer
yeah what
are you looking for to throw your weight
behind to put your imagination into in a
film so for me this was
the second film i had exact produced and
you know i'm still learning the ropes i
don't pretend like i'm
the the big boss on set but for me
what's so exciting is getting to be
involved in all of the creative aspects
of film like down to casting wardrobe
storyline
my acting choices other people's choices
i just think that
it's just another added layer of
collaboration that i didn't have before
and i feel like
because i have that i've always wanted
that and like try to tried to
collaborate but because now i have that
title
i feel like i'm allowed to more i guess
and or voice my opinion more
um i
this movie in particular i felt really
grateful because the other exec
producers
kind of took me under their wing and
showed me what goes on behind
closed doors when
just things i didn't know about or
wouldn't even think about and with a
movie like borrego really was a labor of
love we made a
indie film in the middle of the desert
during a pandemic so it was
you know it was very challenging but we
didn't and it was so rewarding
and
um
and i got to say i exactly produced it
as well as acted in it which is pretty
cool yeah
yeah you know it's
i i've seen you talk about
wanting the challenge of this and when i
was watching i was like oh my god like
being out there
in the elements in the heat and then in
the cold and then just i mean i don't
know how long you guys were out there
for but
how does that affect
your relationship with the character
with your scene partner does it
being out there and within the elements
just change everything for you and just
make it so real it really does it really
does there's something about
feeling
holy crap how am i gonna run up this
mountain again as lucy
but as ellie fighting to get away from
something like there's just this whole
it's a different thing like you said
when you are
in it and you're in it and you we just
committed to it i knew for
four
i guess we shot for four weeks that i
was gonna be exhausted in every sense of
the word but like
so is my character so use it so i used
it um but for me
the physical stuff wasn't even the
hardest it was more
ellie's storyline is just
tragic you know she's someone who's
running away from
her life
and as we all know like that just
doesn't work for people like your life
is going to catch up with you and you
actually have to
face what's hurting you and so when you
find out what's happened to ellie's
character
and then you find out what's happened
you find out why tomas is working for
the drug cartel and then they have this
connection at that fireplace scene
um
the movie becomes about something
different it becomes about like human
connection and
that's really why i wanted to do the
movie was because
yes of course it's an action thriller
and those are really fun but the movie
has heart and it matters and you really
feel for the characters so that was
where the hardest work was for me was
building ellie's storyline
yeah it's it's clear that you've got a
love for like
um
for film from top to bottom all the
aspects of it uh when are we gonna see
you with your name on the director's
chair ooh good question you know the
older i get
i i used to
think i couldn't handle it because being
a good a director is hard but being a
good director
and being a people because you have to
be a people person
you have to be kind you don't have to be
kind but you should be kind
um you have to have a vision you have to
wear so many different hats and
i am a very anxious person so i didn't i
used to think i couldn't handle it but
the older i get i'm like
maybe so because i have ideas and i
um
i'd have a lot to learn but
maybe maybe one day we'll see
maybe one day maybe on the new pretty
little liars perhaps could be oh i'm so
curious that was a good leeway i loved
how you um brought that one in um i am
excited to see it though
i have a friend who's on the reboot and
uh
she can't tell me much but it sounds
like it's gonna be pretty
dark pretty dark
but it sounds good very cool very cool
listen congratulations again um i'm
excited for you i'm excited for people
to see this also so great job on